i secretly hope i wake up one day and
don't want to buy the jets anymore
and don't want to work the way i want to
work and want to do something else
completely left field and i
can't wait to wake up look in the camera
and be like i'm out and leave and not
give a [ __ ] what anybody says
oh he figured out that he couldn't do it
so he did this or see you can't work
like garyvee
he got burned out like don't give a [ __ ]
if i genuinely in my soul
feel it i can't wait to go build [ __ ]
sand castles
in peru for the rest of my life so
[ __ ] empowering man because we get
trapped by the identity that we've
formerly
said he pegged it for me he goes you
know what your superpower is i'm like
what he's like you don't judge yourself
i'm like
[ __ ] you're right and that's what that
was this is why i'm so hot in this
judgment thing the great blessing of my
life is that i don't judge myself
i hold myself accountable doesn't mean
you go and be reckless when i
[ __ ] up and i suck i'm not delusional
it's just that i just don't over
judge it everyone's tearing themselves
down the [ __ ] are you doing that for
everybody else is doing it for you
stop beating yourself up